hi there steve kaufman here
and today i want to talk about how i
learned mandarin chinese
[Music]
now before we get into that if you enjoy
these videos
uh please subscribe you can
click on the bell to get notifications
and by all means come and join me at
link to learn languages now
how i went about learning mandarin
chinese first of all let me tell you
that i was 23 at the time
and the reason i
started learning mandarin chinese is
because i was working for the canadian
government trade commissioner service
and canada was about to recognize the
people's republic of china they wanted
to train some people in chinese i was i
was lucky enough to be selected and off
i went to hong kong
actually i had a choice of going to the
defense language institute in monterey
but i decided instead i would rather go
to hong kong which is a chinese
environment although not a mandarin
speaking environment so
i took about a year to get my level up
to what was a sort of british foreign
service exam
translating newspaper editorials from
english to chinese chinese to english i
had to write a diplomatic note in
chinese by hand and obviously speak and
translate and so forth took me about a
year but the important thing about being
in hong kong is that it was not a
mandarin-speaking environment so that
you know my total immersion in chinese
was done without the benefit of being
surrounded by people who speak the
language
so how was i able to do that when i
think back on it now
the main thing and i'll go into detail
as to how i went about learning
you know their characters and and
learning to read and speak
but but the main thing was the
motivation and that's the big story for
me china represented
uh you know this exotic
world civilization culture and and i'll
get into more detail on that but but i
needed to be very much motivated
because it was a lot of work i had to
learn characters i had to learn the
tones
and i was motivated by my interest in
the culture today it's much easier to
learn languages we didn't have access to
mp3 files we had great big clunky uh
open real tape recorders most uh texts
had no
uh you know obviously you didn't have
online dictionaries you didn't have
online anything today we have link where
i learned you know i started learning
russian at age 60 on link i started
learning arabic and persian i'm still
learning them i'm 75 it's just so much
easier
um the whole you know the the iphone the
the internet everything has made
language learning easier including link
of course
but back then we didn't have that so i
needed very strong motivation of course
today
if you have all of the advantages of
learning with modern technology
and you're motivated then you've got the
best of both worlds and you need to be
motivated so to me the motivation was
that
here was this ancient civilization
unknown to me
uh you know
4 000 years of history chinese talk
about 5 000 years but
there's 4 000 years in terms of
you know
some kind of record of some government
there and
for long periods of history china was
the most developed country in the world
uh probably up until you know three four
five hundred years ago and all of a
sudden this this self-satisfied
sophisticated
almost world unto itself center of the
sort of the culture of east asia all of
a sudden
comes into contact with a civilization
western european or not necessarily
western but european civilization
that has benefited from
the uh you know the science the
enlightenment the the industrial
revolution and and has gun powder now
and has other
technical advantages that the chinese
don't have and they're faced with the
fact that they are at a disadvantage
and so here's this new culture how do
you react to it when i think of say the
qing dynasty which was actually
a manchurian
dynasty but more or less assimilated
into chinese culture and then in 1911
you have the the what they call the
nationalist revolution
and all of a sudden it's no longer you
know an imperial state it's some kind of
republic but that period from 1911
through to 1949 was to me the most
fascinating period of china when i was
learning in hong kong we had to read the
people's daily and mouse thoughts and
all of that kind of stuff and it wasn't
very interesting because a lot of the
sort of communist boilerplate
uh you know ideology and stuff is just a
lot of
repetition of of certain themes that are
kind of reorgan divorced from reality
but
the novels of the 20th century in china
the the struggles as as intellectuals
try try to
come to terms with this new civilization
and how much of the new civilization
should they you know accept or integrate
into their civilization what can they
maintain of theirs
to me there must have been an amazing
uh you know intellectual struggle
and of course then there were different
you know
answers there was a communist answer
there was a
you know who sure was more of a liberal
answer there was more of a fascist
answer there were lots of answers as was
the case in many other countries and i'm
discovering that in arabic or in persian
when you see a 19th century egypt or
19th century
iran have to deal with this you know
collision now with these very arrogant
westerners who want to impose their uh
will uh on this
very proud civilization so that to me
was was interesting so if i look at what
i did
you know first of all you can see behind
me lots of chinese books okay and so i
did a lot of reading i started with this
20 lectures in chinese culture and i
must admit that you know reading about
the history of china you know 1500 years
ago or more recently some of the
declarations by
by uh you know um
sun yat-sen for example the sort of
nationalist revolution and then you know
mao's thought and all of that reading
about it in chinese
was very exhilarating for me
i followed that 20 lectures book up with
and i should say that before i got into
that before i started reading
we had
this
where i went to school new
asia college in hong kong kowloon side
it was part of the yale and china
program so there and there's so many
books in the yale and china program
and the starter book for them was
chinese dialogues which was a series of
dialogues spoken rapid fire or so it
seemed to me
and they used their own uh
transliteration system it wasn't opinion
so i became accustomed to words and
sounds for a good i think two or three
months before we started into reading
and learning the characters
once i had some characters then i could
get into the 20 lectures in chinese
culture although we had no audio for it
which is unfortunate
and also this intermediate reader in uh
chinese modern chinese lots of emphasis
on patterns
and to me
the secret to learning chinese is don't
use a traditional dictionary because
it's very time consuming and you'll forg
in any case any dictionary once you
close the dictionary you've forgotten
what was there but with the chinese
dictionary and i got lots of them it
takes so long to look a word up it's
it's a complete waste of time
i only dealt with reading material where
there was a glossary behind each chapter
of course nowadays that's no longer
necessary because you have online
dictionaries and so if you're reading a
link you can look up words immediately
you can save them to a database there's
so many more things that you can do now
that weren't available back in those
days but so the first thing is don't use
a traditional dictionary which today you
don't need to do
and the second thing was don't get tied
up in grammatical explanations because
the the grammarians tried to get in
there and create all kinds of terms and
stuff i never looked at any of that
stuff i dealt strictly with patterns
here's how they say it and here's how we
say it in english here's how they say it
in chinese
and if i do enough reading and
eventually enough listening i will get
used to those patterns
in chinese without worrying about
grammatical explanations
oh i did want to show you you know
as i said passion is part of it
obviously and i like the the characters
and i had these 1000 flash cards with
the what's known as the radical which
determines you know the sort of the
meaning of the character to some extent
was in red and i went through those i
had sort of a self-styled space
repetition system that i used
but eventually of course you come to
terms with the
tones and it's very difficult
to remember
the tones of individual words so i
listen to a lot of xiangshan and i have
at home i have a lot of cds of xiangtong
i just grabbed a few here my favorite is
hobalin and he wasn't able to grab one
of his
but these shengshou are comedians
it's like a comic dialogue
and they exaggerate the pronunciation as
they're trying to be funny and
and i just found them you know
especially hobalin i just it was almost
like listening to music
[Music]
um
[Music]
that helped me with my tones because you
have to get the tones inside a phrase of
some kind so if i hear these tones these
these uh phrases bouncing around in my
brain it helped me
even though the uh the sunshine comic
dialogues
contain a lot of references to
historical characters or to literature
and things of that nature that i
didn't
you know had no
idea of
uh so i didn't understand that well but
it was the music of those dialogues that
helped me so that was the other thing
that was very useful for me in learning
tones is to do a lot of listening to
that kind of material now i have here
two boxes
of cds
of which i haven't yet had time to
listen to i kind of set them aside you
know home no hmong and i don't know how
many
how many cds and i've got you know
countless uh sunshine cds and and
historical cds and there's so much stuff
and of course nowadays you don't even
have to go i used to go to when i was
traveling into china
uh you know in 2003 maybe when i went
there to promote my book
uh so i bought all this stuff but now of
course you can go online and you can
find
youtube videos which by the way you can
import into link with the uh subtitles
and that becomes a lesson
and so there's so many more things that
you can do that i couldn't do back in
those days so just to summarize and i i
would recommend that you check out the
video that i did on how i learned french
and that was of course the first
call it language that i wanted to learn
to a level of fluency
and compare that to my experience with
learning chinese and you'll see that the
common denominator is that i i developed
a passion for certain aspects of chinese
civilization of french civilization and
that's what sort of drove me to overcome
the obvious difficulties and the
difficulties are not insurmountable
chinese for example has the advantage
that once you have characters it's easy
to build vocabulary because they are
in the new words in the way we
understand words are combinations of
different characters
the grammar in chinese is if i compare
to slavic grammar it's very very
straightforward
but you have to learn the characters and
you have to tackle the tones so with
each language there are difficulties to
overcome these difficulties you have to
basically have a passion
and i'm not going to speak in chinese
today but you could refer to
some of my videos where i have had
discussions in chinese
and
yeah i've maintained it
i've maintained it and even though i
don't have much occasion to speak
chinese uh i think i speak chinese
better today than when i wrote my exam
exam back in 1969 even though
i was able to write then and today i
would have a lot of difficulty in fact i
can't write by hand in chinese i can
write on the computer but back then i
could but today because i occasionally
revisit chinese and i listen to cds and
content and we have chinese friends here
in vancouver i think i speak better now
than i did back then so there you have
it i'm kind of rushing through it so i
don't i don't want
this video to be too long but that's a
brief uh sort of introduction on how i
learned mandarin chinese thanks for
listening
[Music]